morning Hank good morning John it's a
Paper Towns release party and with the
end from the fiveawesomegirls Jodi my
agent deal with free Katherine your life
and ridiculously amazingly Alex and
Charlie from London hey Beth
alright so nothing gets bad and Charlie
came here instead of meeting the Queen
of England no joke Paper Towns is a book
about a bunch of people who are
constantly miss imagining each other
because they're thinking about one
another as something other than a person
here we are stuck inside of our skin
encased in closures and it's very
difficult to imagine another person as
they would imagine themselves I never
like think about myself and think like
that guy sucks on Carrie Thanks I wonder
if you ever considered teaching oh yeah
I would love to that's two cooks yeah
yeah I mean I love I love books I love
literature and I love I love talking
about about folks with young people and
trying to read critically together and
that's something that I really enjoy
finding hugely fulfilling so I
definitely think about um it doesn't
think about teaching I wouldn't I don't
think I want to teach writing because I
don't think I know anything about it but
I know I like to read on I like to read
books with people at Tony I am in a
diner with some of the coolest people in
the world right now John Green who's
famous over here we have scott
westerfeld's is famous and then we have
Maureen Johnson right here who's famous
and eating Charlie I'm famous as well
you can say that in air mommy hugs
responsible to work for the largest tag
project in history Kaelyn a hill you
guys are being Australian yeah castles
that grandpa's like after the coolness
I could use a ringer slip my best friend
and then I saw the other day and I was
like I want to I understand how these
videos get made because it's like way
awesome in real life and then on the
internet you're kind of like why am I
watching this but if you were there it's
amazing she's got a ringtone oh he's
dancin it didn't take long for that if
you dance party in this place what do
you been up to here now D just gonna
chilling having a look around New York
yeah at the top line he was like Paper
Towns much New York and I thought I like
New York and paper tempus and I'm John
Green actually I just finished popped
out that morning so Charlie was sitting
opposite me and I said Charlie amigos
New York and he kind of mumble yeah I
didn't say yeah first thing I was like
okay well I've put the tickets we leave
you like two and a half days okay will
your mom be okay with this yeah I still
came along oh hello how are you
I just wrote Paper Towns today what do
they all fit for it's a new woman
I just got it I think you're they're
making into a movie look Tom Cruise is
going to play the towel that's what I
heard I haven't read it I got it in the
library with your mom but I understand
it's about paper which is nice I've also
made of trees so that'll be good to be
honest I can't imagine it's actually
that long and sounds like a picture book
but you know but I'm sure it's good John
Green is a good author where we use so
you know we'll be reading that you want
to get the library
someone who's not me in the picture book
section it was the cudgel get like the
Popo
and that is the story from New York City
John I'm in Boston now where we're about
to have another fantastic nerdfighter
event and I will see you in a half an
hour so when we get some dinner with my
parents and our cousin you probably
won't see this before then so I'm not
sure what I'm saying I'll see you then
but I will and for all of you who
couldn't make to New York or to Boston
or any of the other nerdfighting events
you still love you very much and we will
always be right here on the Internet the
Internet is our first place it's our
last place far as I'm concerned it's the
place to be and while I will see John
very shortly all of you will see him on
Monday